was passiert mit all diesen menschen
auch hier in deutschland
sie suchen schutz vor putins bomben vor
krieg und tod doch in der vermeintlich
gefundenen sicherheit wird eine 18
jährige ukrainerin opfer eines schweren
verbrechens in dieser düsseldorfer
flüchtlingsunterkunft einem ausflugsboot
am rheinufer sollen zwei männer die
junge frau vergewaltigt haben die
mutmaßlichen täter ein 37 jähriger
tunesier und ein 26 jähriger nigerianer
bei der allerdings im besitz eines
ukrainischen
ausweises seit beginn des krieges
flüchteten bereits mehr als drei
millionen ukraine viele davon in eu
länder wie polen und ungarn da es im
regelfall keine passkontrollen an den
eu-binnengrenzen gibt und ukraine
aufgrund der aktuellen situation auch
ohne visum nach deutschland einreisen
dürfen ist die lage unübersichtlich
auch die bundespolizei kontrolliert nur
ukrainische flüchtlinge wenn sie
auffälligkeiten feststellen nach
bild-informationen stoßen polizisten im
grenzgebiet immer öfter auf flüchtlinge
die nicht direkt aus der ukraine stammen
sondern zb aus afrika oder dem nahen
osten
doch von stationierten grenzkontrollen
und somit einer kontrollierten einreise
nach deutschland davon sieht unsere
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser ab
es gibt eine völlig andere situation als
2015 müsse dem kriegsgeschehen mitten in
europa zu tun deshalb unterscheidet sich
das von 2015 elementar wir haben
gemeinschaftliches europäisches vorgehen
und dazu haben wir uns mit einer
richtlinie so vereinbart lief es jetzt
machen täglich strömen so mehr als
12.000 flüchtlinge unkontrolliert zu uns
nach deutschland
doch wie viele flüchtlinge tatsächlich
und wer genau einreist darüber haben die
deutschen behörden keinen job die
mutmaßlichen täter aus düsseldorf kommen
gemeinsam mit ihrem späteren opfer und
weiteren ukrainischen flüchtlingen auf
diesem hotel bot unter warum beide
männer neben der tunesischen bzw
nigerianische staatsbürgerschaft auch
die ukrainische besitzen unklar die
beiden mutmaßlichen täter sitzen in
untersuchungshaft die 18 jährige
ukrainerin ist nach polen geflohen sie
fühlt sich nicht mehr sicher in
deutschland
wie können wir diese sicherheit
garantieren wir können wir aber auch
kontrollieren wer kommt darüber sprechen
wir jetzt mit heiko teggatz dem chef der
gewerkschaft der bundespolizei einen
schönen guten morgen herr tigers wir
haben dieses beispiel aus düsseldorf
gesehen dass natürlich die frage
aufwirft wie kann das passieren menschen
suchen zuflucht und dann landen sie hier
sprichwörtlich in der hölle
ja das ist schrecklich was dort in
düsseldorf passiert ist wir beobachten
aber schon seit jahren dieses
kriminalitätsphänomen
unerlaubter einreise schleusungen
menschenhandel und prostitution das ist
eine kriminalität geografie die nur
schwer voneinander zu trennen und hier
sind die sicherheitsbehörden von bund
und ländern gefordert dieses
kriminalitätsphänomen bereits bei der
einreise zu identifizieren und dann
gezielt zu bekämpfen ist hier aber gar
nicht klar ob das in dem fall geholfen
hätten hier geht es um eine 18 jahre
alte ukrainerin die auf diesem schiff
untergebracht wurde mit zwei männern die
ganz offenbar auch einen ukrainischen
pass hatten die mechanische und
irakischer herkunft waren aber offenbar
ja mit dem ukrainischen pass hier
hingekommen sind
ja wenn ich wer nicht aber die die
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine schützen
will dann kann ich das nicht nur bei der
einreise bei der registrierung oder bei
der verteilung machen sondern ich muss
auch staatlich kontrollieren wenig mit
wem wo unterbringen letztendlich und das
fehlt leider
in der momentanen situation völlig der
automobilen verlangen ist der verzeihung
hat es ist zu viel verlangt in solchen
situationen wo so viele menschen kommen
oder ist das nicht schlecht eine ganz
selbstverständliche erwartung an den
start das man halt weiß wer reinkommt
wer rausgeht
ja das ist das ist aus meiner sicht eine
selbstverständlichkeit und ich kann
ihnen auch versichern dass die
bundespolizei mit ihrem personal und mit
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen
hochprofessionell tagtäglich mit dieser
aufgabe zu tun hat zumindest an den
grenzen und an den bahnhöfen und deshalb
ist es für mich und auch für meine
kolleginnen und kollegen unverständlich
dass die bundesregierung ganz
offensichtlich hat schon seit 20 tagen
völlig gelähmt ist und keine
entscheidung trifft um ein geordnetes
verfahren in diese situation runs als
wir uns da auch mal ganz konkret
reingehen hergatz beispielsweise die
situation hier in der hauptstadt am
hauptbahnhof dort kommen tausende
menschen geflüchtete an suchen jetzt
einen sicheren hafen und sonst sind so
viele freiwillige und es hängen überall
auch schilder die davor warnen das ist
natürlich auch immer wieder menschen
gibt die auf menschenhandel aus sind sie
diese situation ausnutzen natürlich sind
da beamte vor ort fühlen sie sich da im
stich gelassen was kann konkret
passieren beispielsweise in dieser
situation dass man den flüchtlingen
hilft in sicherheit zu sein dass man
aber auch die beamten dabei unterstützt
ihre arbeit zu machen also zunächst
einmal möchte ich auch mal ganz
herzlichen dank an alle freiwilligen
aussprechen die sich so engagieren im
umgang mit den ankommenden flüchtlingen
um auf ihre frage nochmal einzugehen wir
hätten uns sehr gewünscht als
bundespolizei dass diese züge eben nicht
direkt aus aus warschau oder woher auch
immer in berlin ankommen sich die türen
öffnen und die menschen die dort drin
sind auf sich gestellt sind wir hätten
uns schon sehr gewünscht auch hier eine
vernünftige kontrolle hin zu bekommen
solche züge beispielsweise auf den
bahnsteigen zu separieren das technische
hilfswerk das deutsche rote kreuz mit
einzubinden die bundespolizei mit
einzubinden um eine registrierung und
wer anschließend kontrollierte
verteilung auf vorzunehmen aber da
scheint sich unsere bundesregierung sehr
schwer zu tun vermutlich war möglich
auch weil der berliner senat sich da
sehr schwer tut ja am beispiel
hauptbahnhof hier jetzt mal konsequent
flagge zu zeigen noch mal butter bei die
fische wäre hält sie davon ab von der
arbeit die sie eigentlich tun wollen ist
das eine persönliche frage also von
einzelnen politikern von einzelnen
regierenden ist das eine technische
frage ist kompliziert alles hin zu
stellen oder dem bürokratische man das
ist eine rein politisch bürokratische
angelegenheit die bundespolizei ist mit
ihrer bundesbereitschaftspolizei
jederzeit in der lage auch zunächst
einmal notdürftig sowas zu errichten was
ich gerade beschrieben habe das kann man
an den grenzen tun das kann man auch an
den bahnhöfen machen hier fehlt es
schlichtweg an eine an mit an der
übernahme der politischen verantwortung
sowas anzuordnen und das ist das was
meine kolleginnen und kollegen überhaupt
nicht verstehen können und wo ich auch
sage als vorsitzender der die
bundespolizeigewerkschaft wir dürfen
nicht zulassen dass unsere kolleginnen
und kollegen die hoch professionell
arbeiten und diesen job können nur nicht
dürfen und politik nicht verheizt werden
stellen sie uns das einmal was ihnen
auch die kolleginnen und kollegen
schildern in ihrem alltag ist also die
menschen die kollegen die am bahnhof
stehen die vielleicht an den grenzen
stehen die versuchen ihre arbeit
auszuüben mit sicherheit bringen wie
viele geschichten mit unverständnis
darüber über die situation dass sie
nicht besser helfen können dass sie
dabei offenbar auch gehemmt
zurückgehalten werden was erzählen ihnen
die kollegen ja genau das ist der punkt
viele kolleginnen und kollegen gerade am
berliner hauptbahnhof oder auch in
frankfurt oder berichten regelmäßig über
die schicksale die dort die dort auf sie
einprasseln da steckt man auch nicht
einfach so weg und wenn man dann auch
noch von den von dem rechtlich zur
verfügung gestellten mitteln hilflos
dieser situation gegenüber steht dann
ist das doppelt schlimm danke herzlich
an den vorsitzenden der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft in der bei der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft danke
heiko teggatz